in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Michael
and mackynzie are here hey guys how are
you great how are you better than I
deserve
welcome it's good to have you where do
you guys live Arizona Phoenix Arizona
whoa
so I'm guessing you caught a good
Southwest flight over to Nashville no no
we drove well welcome to Nashville
you're free scream how much have you
paid off we paid off right around eighty
eight thousand dollars very cool and how
long did that take you took us 48 months
four years exactly Wow
and making what kind of money during
that time between 120 and 140 and I also
have to say that we had two babies
obviously we cash flowed two unpaid
maternity leaves and also we're able to
pay down a significant amount on our
mortgage so Wow yeah big strides now
what do y'all do for a living
we're both area managers for four
different businesses I'm in the health
service organization and he works for a
rental car company very cool so what
kind of debt was the eighty eight
thousand mixture of everything yeah was
about thirty five thousand in student
loans between the both of us
car and credit cards credit cards about
30 25 on the car so you guys are just
kind of normal yep normal sucks so you
decide not to do that anymore
what happened forty eight months ago
tell me about your journey yeah
I have always been interested in
personal finance and my mom knew that
and she heard a radio show of yours just
of people sharing this story isn't
paying off debt and she said how
wonderful it was and really thought I
would enjoy it so I picked up the Total
Money Makeover and started to read it
and I loved it so much that I said Mike
you got to hear this so we were on
vacation friend's wedding and we got the
audiobook and we listened to it the
whole way and we were we've been on
board ever since cool so you sat down
after that and decided we're gonna do a
budget and we're going to start selling
things and we're gonna get out of debt
and we're gonna cut our lifestyle
absolutely so was there a big budget
fight along the way or at the start or
not no honestly we actually fought a lot
more before yes
you couldn't be more opposite when it
comes to almost everything but the one
thing that we both have in common are
our long term goals and that's really
what attracted people and in competitive
so once we knew where we needed to be
then then all of our other priorities
went out the window this was the most
important thing and we're gonna get
there so it changes everything when you
do that yeah absolutely absolutely I'll
have you on the same page and both of
you in agreement that this is the
priority yes when you do that everything
else falls away and you win that's right
that's exactly how this works well
congratulations you guys thank you so
much for so what was the hardest part of
this I'm impatient I'm terribly
impatient person so exactly exactly and
we bought a fixer-upper and so you know
just the the remodels and things like
that that we had dreams of doing all of
that got put on hold and and just being
patient we have long hot summers in
Arizona and so our businesses are slower
usually during that time too and so it
would just there was months and months
where we didn't get any make any headway
and that was always a bit of a challenge
yeah we have spikes income during the
springtime and then through the summers
our slow time so got you for her to wait
and have a couple months in there we're
only paying you know 1800 other months
so yeah yeah big chunks not going not
falling away it's harder to harder to
stay motivated that's fun so which one
of these debts when you paid it off you
went
I hate you people I'm so glad you're
going I think the student loan you know
it just it it lasted so much longer than
we were thinking you know and so it just
I hate you know I thought it would be
paid off within six months after I
graduated that's how I envisioned it in
my head and how long how long have you
been out of school I've been out since
2006 almost nine years way longer than I
thought it's always longer that
everybody thinks so you guys have been
married how long we've been married
since 2010 yeah so five years okay yes
so it wasn't long after that that you
started this one year one year after the
journey we went to a friend's wedding
and and it's all she wrote
way to go you guys congratulations and
how old are your kids we have a three
and a half year old and a 10 month olds
that just turned ten months today and
their names
Brooks and Beckett Brooks and Beckett
yeah very cool all right Michael and
McKenzie Brooks and back at Phoenix
Arizona eighty-eight thousand dollars
paid off in forty eight months making
him 120 to 140 count it down let's hear
a debt free scream and the crowd goes
wild I love it I love it I love it way
to go that's awesome congratulations you
guys